If you have a diverse musical taste...
...and there is a tiny little hippie spirit somewhere inside you,...
...you should fly to England in June.
One of the most famous festivals in Europe is the Glastonbury Festival in England.
"Glasto," which is the short name, takes place at Worth Farm, Somerset, in southwest England.
There are a number of legends and spiritual traditions connected with this area.
The festival is a giant multi event...
...where the largest outdoor countryside music and performing arts festival in the world is held.
For four days in June every year, it attracts 170,000 visitors...
...who can enjoy over 700 performances of music, theater, comedy, dance, circus, cabarets...
...and countless other forms of art on 900 acres of grounds.
Among the performers are the biggest and most famous musicians of the world.
The festival is held in any weather conditions and is never canceled.